Oh Kyrios pride arose kalimera Cesare
his ease in addressing to Protoss
immersed in America via tax in a
dealership it repeated the gamut in
prophecy a Tony Perez piston tone
Deshawn key to Perry validus never [ __ ]
honest if a fella my penny suitable et /
he didn't Matata my PO validate my
Anasazi or Lobos material because here
two cuts the I okay meeting because it's
a rod see geologic art afresh mopey
Wanda's toso dignity Vav Casilla also
cater electronica sistema de caso de se
maybe a facialist initially Mickey clue
extra no mottos disappear epistle always
a Peter prosecutors miniature thank you
very much mr. president
very good morning honorable members the
Commission is strongly committed to
protecting and restoring existing
forests both within the European Union
and worldwide to descend the
comprehensive legislative framework
exists at the EU level in particular
many forests are protected under the
birds and habitats directives
these directives require that some
forest habitats
be maintained or restored at favourable
conservation status currently 23% of the
European Union's forest area is part of
the Natura 2000 Network of protected
sites in addition species protection
rules under both the birds and habitats
directives apply within the whole EU
territory environmentally
represent natural and indispensable
allies in the promotion of environmental
rights another tool is the directive on
environmental crime in the European
Union the Commission is currently
evaluating how the directive has
contributed to the fight against
environmental crime the Commission is
currently carrying out a wide public
consultation open until January 2020 and
will assess the need to review this
legislation or improve its
implementation
finally the timber regulation aims to
prevent trade in illegally harvested
timber and timber product and the rental
crime is also considered a threat to
European security and to the well-being
of citizens it has therefore been
included in the EU policy cycle against
serious and organised crime that covers
the period from 2018 to 2021 the
European Union policy cycles primary
objective is to increase cooperation
amongst law enforcement services and EU
agencies to disrupt organized crime
groups through operational actions it is
important to recall that member states
are responsible for implementing the
relevant rules as well as for taking the
appropriate enforcement measures
including sanctions and penalties the
commission monitors the implementation
of these rules and take section when
needed the European Union is also
providing financial means for the
protection restoration and sustainable
management of forests in line with the
EU for a strategy the
in unions rural development funds under
the Common Agricultural Policy are the
main source of funding for forests
amounting to eight point two billion
euros of public expenditure in the
current MMF mff period 2014-2020 last
but not least the recent communication
on stepping up the election to protect
and restore the world's forests shows
that the European Union is increasing
its efforts to step up global action
against biodiversity loss this is
currently discussed in council and
European Parliament in this context I
have to highlight again the important
role of the timber regulation which
applies to both timber logged in third
countries and imported into the European
Union and to domestic timber logged in
the European Union the Commission has
been alerted on reported cases of
continued illegal logging in some member
states including in primary forests and
is carefully assessing the situation on
the specific case of Romania the
Commission is working with authorities
to assess the situation it is also in
the process of analyzing Copernicus
satellite imagery of logging activities
in a tour a 2,000 protected areas thank
you